[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois kerridge est
journaliste à vanity fair qui publie les
visées à la plage un livre très
instructif sur les vacances du président
de la république où l'on s'aperçoit
qu'en 50 ans tout a changé
on est passé de vacances qui durait un
mois et demi que l'on pouvait passer
chez des amis milliardaires dans un
palace cinq étoiles à l'étranger ou à
redécorer brégançon avec l'argent du
contribuable à nos jours où l'on n'a
presque plus le droit de prendre des
vacances surtout pas chez des riches
encore moins à l'étranger et il faut
travailler tout le temps surtout en
vacances et l'on commence comme
d'habitude par une image symbolisant
notre époque
voici celles que vous avez choisi
pierrick 'j'ai c'est valéry giscard
d'estaing avec le lourd avec nounours de
bonne nuit les petits
j'ai choisi cette image qui n'est pas
vraiment d'actualité en fait mais qui me
rappelle quelque chose qui est arrivé il
ya quelques semaines c'est emmanuel
macron avec les youtuber vous savez
mcfly carlitos est cette vidéo qui a
fait beaucoup parler des gens qui ont
salué cette vidéo qui ont dit que le
président justement il communiquait avec
les outils de son temps il parlait à la
jeunesse à un an de la présidentielle
et puis d'autres qui ont dit que c'était
vraiment la dégradation la déflagration
de de la fonction présidentielle
et finalement on marque valéry giscard
d'estaing à l'époque il accueillait
nounours de bonne nuit les petits la
star des enfants à l'elysée ça c'est
pour je crois son premier noël à
l'elysée on va voir d'ailleurs parce que
la photo sur les larges et on voit les
enfants voilà ces enfants qui écoute le
président rogge qui regarde nous voilà
et il invitait tout le monde à l'elysée
mireille mathieu
beaucoup y avait il y avait d'autres
d'autres artistes pour ce premier arbre
de noël une tradition d'ailleurs qui
sera dieu que continuera mitterrand puis
chirac c'est une vraie tradition
élyséennes et donc je trouvais ça assez
marrant finalement de voir un président
avec la star des enfants là plutôt de
l'époque et emmanuel macron finalement
voilà il fait la même chose et un
président mais je d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on verra avec les présidents en
vacances il sait se servir des outils de
communication de son temps alors les
présidents vacances quand j'ai vu votre
livre je me suis dit comment on peut
traiter d'un sujet pareil ça va pas être
intéressant et en fait c'est passionnant
parce que c'est c'est le récit de nos
tolérances à nous les français on voit
bien qu'elles ont beaucoup changé depuis
cinq ou 60 ans alors commençons
[Musique]
pierre-yves gg j'ai découvert grâce à
votre livre qu'il y avait le q1 avant
forme de brégançon cette forteresse
militaire sans fenêtre un quasiment ce
sont des meurtrières comme on va le voir
tout à l'heure basse de plafond
la prise de la résidence d'été des
présidents de la république de la
troisième et de la quatrième république
c'était le château de vizille dans
l'isère un château de conte de fées avec
un parc gigantesque
on le voit derrière moi ils s'en
remettaient pas à l'époque un les
adresses et les français d beaucoup
moins regardants qu'aujourd'hui
complètement 1 c'est presque un le
château de la belle au bois dormant il
ya des grandes tours il ya un grand il
ya un grand parc avec un étang des
signes c'est vraiment un conte de fée
puis vous regardez toutes ces montagnes
cette verdure
oui et les présidents près de grenoble
voilà et les présidents adorait adorait
visite notamment albert lebrun et madame
lebrun la présidente comme on disait à
l'époque adorait même si elle trouvait
ça un peu trop grand parce qu'il y avait
des marches partout partout partout et
il n'y avait pas encore d'ascenseur est
alors le général de gaulle lui il y est
allé une nuit et où il n'a pas trop aimé
c'est surtout yvonne de gaulle 1 qui
n'aimait pas ce qu'ils veulent de vol
elle n'aimait rien aprr la boisserie
leur résidence à colombey les deux
églises
elle n'aimait pas l'elysée elle voulait
pas mettre les pieds à brégançon elle
aimait la musique donc finalement visite
a été un peu oublié
c'est un musée c'est devenu le musée de
la révolution française dont l'oubli
souvent c'est vrai qu'on connaît pas
tous au château de vie alors que c'est
il ya un parc absolument ji quan artère
est ce que c'était il est et il était
très très bien il est très très bien
lieu ristic
ah oui c'était vraiment on se déplaçait
avec toute ma cour a encore un sous la
troisième république tout le monde
venait les conseillers les domestiques
et puis toute la famille aussi les
petits enfants les enfants
il passait du temps à pêcher dans la
paix chez justement dans les temps et
c'était les vraies vacances du président
de la cecc on admettait à l'époque qu'un
président de la république il avait
moins de pouvoir aujourd'hui on
admettait qu'il prenne des vacances
complètement alors pendant ces vacances
là il continuait à recevoir quand même
les notables du coin le curé du point
l'abbé bien sûr il y avait toujours
quand même un petit peu
chose qui se fait plus trop un peu à
brégançon mâcon reçoit angela merkel ou
theresa may ou la limousine mais il
reçoit pas les notables du coin là il
recevait le toujours le préfet voit la
fin donc il restait quand même dans son
rôle de président mais il prenait le
temps de lire de regarder des films déjà
à l'époque et puis de se promener et
celle du cinéma comme voilà enfin une
salle de cinéma de l'époque alors le
général de gaulle lui va prendre le fort
de brégançon comme résidence officielle
du président de la république on voit
d'ailleurs des pages de votre livre et
des photos
chaque président a droit à ses photos de
vacances à on enverra un certain nombre
le fort de brégançon finalement va pas
lui plaire il y passe une seule nuit et
ils préfèrent retourner à la boisserie
alors je voudrais qu'on s'arrête sur la
boisserie à colombey les deux églises
on voit bien que tout a changé là on
voit le fort de brégançon jeu cette
forteresse militaire 1
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est vrai qu'on s'est vraiment pas très
agréable le fort de brégançon
c'est vraiment pas le lieu de
villégiature rêver comme ça de
l'extérieur c'est plutôt joli mais à
l'intérieur c'est très bas de plafond
comme vous disiez des petites fenêtres
avec des lits en fer c'est pas le grand
confort un sais pas c'est pas une audace
voit bien que les a punis ont été
envoyés à brégançon c'est une punition
mais justement j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête
sur la boisserie parce que ça dit pas
mal de choses de notre changement
d'époque aussi d'abord la boisserie
c'est une maison que charles de gaulle à
acheter en viager est la propriétaire
vous le raconter est morte au bout de
deux ans oui nos alliés dans sa
baignoire
un autre président on aura l'enquêté et
il y aurait eu des rumeurs d'assassinats
de complot qui perdurait encore
aujourd'hui leurs amis avait dit à
l'époque c'est la seule bonne affaire
que le général de gaulle a réussi à
faire dans sa vie c'est sûr il a payé
par deux orale est évidemment a vraiment
les soupçons aurait dû se porter sur lui
aujourd'hui on en fait tout un plat à
l'époque je me poste il est plus les
journalistes n'est au courant de cette
histoire de goûter de viager ça s'était
passé avant qu'il soit président bien
entendu y ait une autre histoire que
vous racontez qui est très drôle pendant
l'été 1960 il aime pas beaucoup cyclisme
2 go
ça n'intéresse pas mais bon l'étape du
tour qui est extrêmement populaire passe
à colombes et donc il décide d'y aller
on prévient jacques goddet le patron du
tour de france et il immobilise le tour
de france pour que les lèche coureurs
puissent aller saluer pour exemple la
république voilà c'est invraisemblable
on ferait ça aujourd'hui
ce sera un scandale il est il aime pas
ils n'aiment pas le sport de gaulle ils
n'aiment pas le foot il aime pas le le
vélo de même pas aux jeux olympiques de
grenoble non non c'est vraiment pas
quelque chose qui l'intéresse mais c'est
yvonne de gaulle là encore alors il
était en vacances à colombey elle dit le
tour de france passe à colombey il
faudrait peut-être qu'on y est et où il
se laisse convaincre par yvonne de
gaulle et ccc est organisée le matin
même le les responsables du tour de
france la police sont prévenus à la
dernière minute c'est pas dans l'agenda
présidentiel si je peux dire est donc
bon il se mêle à la foule en plus il est
très grand on le voit arriver derrière
et là tout ce ci mobilise tout le monde
salue le général il y en a quelques-uns
quand même qui se faufilait effet dans
le coureur cycliste qui ne veulent
s'arrêter celui qui va gagner d'ailleurs
là c'est celui qui ne s'arrête pas voilà
mais il est très mal vu de ne pas avoir
salué général de quoi là on lui reproche
son manque de respect à l'égard du
président de la république
c'est vraiment une autre époque c'est
elle c'est magique il faut savoir
qu'aucun journaliste n'a jamais été
admis à l'intérieur de de la boisserie
voir une fois paris match mais il
n'était pas président de la république
et c'est la seule fois voilà il ne
communique pas sur ses vacances de
gaulle c'est ça qui est intéressant
ça va tout va changer avec georges
pompidou qui est plus moderne il faut
bien le dire vous raconter que georges
pompidou il était banquier
sa femme avait une porsche et y passer
ses vacances à saint tropez
voilà c'est les les pompidou c'est quand
même une autre ambiance
c'est en couleur et claude pompidou
adorait prendre des vacances elle disait
j'aimerais avoir des maisons dans toute
la france j'ai des maisons en rêve dans
toute la france elle adorait salle c'est
ce qu'elle préférait
elle aimait pas l'elysée mais l'été les
vacances et les mondanités et les
pompidou il allait à saint tropez il
adorait avec les rothschilds adorait les
mondanités et quand pompidou est devenu
premier ministre
de gaulle il a dix saint-tropez c'est
fini maintenant il faut ces montagnes là
- faut aller en bretagne et finalement
pompidou il est à lille allait dans
trois lieux de vacances différent il
allait parce qu'à l'époque il faut dire
un mois et demi de vacances
un mois et demi les vraies vacances avec
des il amenait pas les dossiers il
jouait vraiment la paix tant c'était ça
où il avait on lui apportait des
dossiers qu'ils signent ils
travaillaient très très vite pompidou il
signa vite fait des dossiers un jour sur
deux et puis il avait vraiment du temps
pour lire pour jouer à la pétanque eux
c'est vrai ou lite avec des amis à
brégançon le pour écrire écrire mais des
écrits personnels à écrire des poésies
donc il avait vraiment du temps et
changer de lieu de vacances trois fois
en un mois et demi donc lâché la
bretagne la bretagne alors la brosse
hâtivement par la bretagne vous dit que
puisque la halle de gaulle avait dit la
bretagne dont killer bretagne ils
veulent chez les bettencourt
déjà chez des amis milliardaires ce qu
on reprochera plus tard à nicolas
sarkozy pompidou le feu en toute
impunité à l'époque ça ne choque
personne non ça ne choque personne et
d'ailleurs valéry giscard d'estaing le
fera aussi une première était chez des
amis milliardaires et donc pompidou
après il loue un petit manoir en breton
en bretagne ou dans lequel il va quinze
jours au début de l'été puis après c'est
brégançon puis on oublie souvent savent
pas ce qu on parle souvent de la
bergerie de mitterrand fin mai pompidou
avait aussi sa bergerie à cajarc
voilà d'ailleurs et alors là c'était un
peu vous savez le hameau d'arendt je me
suis trompé pardon me dit dans
l'oreillette c'est brégançon se
confondrait grand mais c'est à oui c'est
la terrasse mais à cajarc c'était
vraiment une bergerie qu'ils avaient
faire rénover il est mais justement ce
côté très champêtre on joue aux paysans
dont qu'ils avaient des moutons mais il
n'en faisait rien mais c'était joli leur
fils alain pompidou ce qui m'a dit c'est
que la secal jarre voilà ça faisait
jolie lui chat sèche elle monte à cheval
ils recevaient beaucoup d'amis il avait
il avait fait alors on parle souvent de
la piscine de brégançon justement là il
avait fait une piscine dans une vieille
citerne donc tout était vraiment on joue
aux paysans d'ailleurs il invitait
souvent les paysans du coin va les
années 70 voilà il disait que c'était
vraiment et puis il disait que cette
cette bergerie justement un quasar ce
serait le rêve de tout le monde dans
quelques décennies et c'est un peu ça
tout le monde rêverait dans quelques
décennies d'avoir des yeux frais le
matin du bon lait bouffe et ben ils
s'étaient pas trompés qui est très
intéressant aussi c'est qu'on voit tous
nos présidents pendant l'été qui vont à
la messe de gaulle va à la messe georges
pompidou va la messe à mitterrand
giscard allait à la messe
chirac va à la messe encore chirac
beaucoup même souvent sa seule sortie à
brégançon
c'est la mère parce que il l'aimé pas
trop il voulait il voulait réglementer
un peu sa médiatisation donc il sortait
quand il avait décidé quand claude
chirac qui est de sa fille et en même
temps sa conseillère presse avait décidé
qu'ils allaient sortir est souvent la
seule sortie c'était justement la messe
le dimanche matin il était très ami avec
le curé de bormes-les-mimosas surtout
bernadette chirac assez bigote
finalement clic et d'être très ami avec
le curé de balle mimosa et finalement
cette messe le dimanche matin ça
renvoyait l'image qu'ils avaient envie
de renvoyer l'image d'un bon grand-père
de deux un bon père de famille un bon
grand-père avec des valeurs un de droite
donc c'était c'était cette image les
vacances servait aussi à ça mais
aujourd'hui ce serait très mal vue
d'aller à la messe ce serait très mal vu
j'en avais parlé justement avec l'ancien
curé de burnley mimosas et me dit ah je
sais pas je sais pas j'y vais c'est sûr
que manuel mâcon vous imaginez si mad
max on allait à la messe aujourd'hui
alors après je pense que gérald vous
l'avez toujours dit qu'il y aller en
tant que personne privée et qu'il
n'allait pas la messe en tant que
président de la république on peut faire
aussi la différence oui oui d'ailleurs
il
il y avait un siège à colombey les deux
églises dans l'église de
colombey-les-deux-églises réservé pour
le général devant l'hôtel et lui préféré
se mettre sur un banc tout au fond faire
en toute discrétion
en tout un homme c'est devant le ta vie
privée effectivement donc je georges
pompidou
il faut bien savoir que quand il
découvre brégançon le général de gaulle
n'ayant passé qu'une nuit tout ça est
dans un état lamentable que pompidou qui
avait déjà re décorer l'elysée va re
décorer brégançon avec des meubles tout
aussi moderne voyons les voilà
d'ailleurs à brégançon georget et claude
pompidou elle va tout redécorer à
l'époque personne n'en fait un plat
qu'on a dépensé de l'argent du
contribuable avons rénové une résidence
privée du enfin une vraie fête dans ce
fils yale du président de la république
tout le monde trouve ça normal voilà et
puis toutes les premières dames vous
voulez corée prévention sera alors que
de pompidou ce sera à la sauce donc très
contemporaine on connaît le style des
pompidou après anne aymone giscard
d'estaing ramènera quelque chose de plus
en voix aux basses à aujourd'hui voilà
que c'est une chose de plus provençal
néo provençal avec des des fauteuils
aussi louis 15 et tout et puis
bernadette chirac alors elle qui avait
une passion pour redécorer les lieux de
la république que ça soit la lanterne à
versailles où brégançon elle a aussi mis
sa petite touche personnelle
après bernadette chirac n'aura pas
vraiment de redécoration de brégançon et
le minimum qui va ya voir ça va faire
scandale mais ne dévoilons pas tout vous
n'êtes on y arrivera passons à passons à
mais d'abord je vais dire quelque chose
que l'on que j'ai fait le rapport en
lisant votre livre
tout le monde sait que georges pompidou
a laissé rentrer les caméras de
télévision à l'elysée
justement pour qu'on voie les
redécoration de madame pompidou il
laissera les caméras rentrée à brégançon
légalement et mais vous ramener à
l'origine de tout ça c'est jackie
kennedy jackie kennedy en 1962 redécore
la maison blanche
parce que les jeunes parce qu'il est
moderne et les centres et les caméras de
télévision
et ça va donner des idées tout le monde
elizabeth ii va faire la même chose à
buckingham quelques années après elle le
regrettera amèrement et les pompidou
font la même chose à leur tour au fond
c'est jackie kennedy qui a lancé cette
mode
oui complètement les kennedy son jeu il
y avait c'est un reportage incroyable où
elle faisait visiter toutes les pièces
de la maison blanche
comme vous le dites après elizabeth 2 ce
sera ce ce documentaire un an avec
elizabeth ii après elle interdira
censurera il est caché encore dans les
coffres de la bbc1 ce documentaire ray
puis pompidou aura été inspiré aussi par
cinq
surtout valérie j
un destin qui lui a do ré kennedy elite
et quand il était au ministère des
finances il avait rencontré kennedy
valéry giscard d'estaing il avait pris
une photo vraiment de groupe i avec lui
il adorait ch et donc vraiment lui là il
a essayé vous voyez là c'est cette photo
justement avec le maillot de bain avec
la famille sur le glas de tous les
enfants c'est vraiment à la sauce
kennedy ça c'est vraiment il faut dire
il a 46 ans il al'âge quasiment des
tenants de 2 du de l'été les dires
arrivants et les jeunes il est moderne
et oui ça fait un peu plus rêver et puis
il faut dire il faut se souvenir
qu'avant lui georges pompidou les
derniers mois il était gonflé par la
marque maladie par les traitements
médicamenteux les français s'inquiétait
pour cette santé que plus on cachait son
état de santé
donc là on a un président jeune en bonne
santé qui s'était d'ailleurs montré vous
souvenez dans les vestiaires d'après un
match de foot pendant la campagne
présidentielle donc son premier et t il
il rejoue il rejoue cette cette mise en
scène du de son corps jeune et fringant
en fait il montre qu'il est en pleine
forme qui les sportifs et aux banques et
aux fonds et montre qu'il n'est pas
georges pompidou et on va voir qu'il ya
dans les vacances des présidents à
chaque fois il notamment le premier
était consiste à montrer qu'on n'est pas
son prédécesseur et on va le voir c'est
systématique et généralement ça se
retourne contre ce contre le crédit dans
le premier et et c'est vraiment une
épreuve d'ailleurs c'est comme ça c'est
l'épreuve du premier était la plupart le
loupe alors le premier était de valéry
giscard d'estaing il le passe chez des
amis milliards d'eur à
saint-jean-cap-ferrat deux choses qui
aujourd'hui serait totalement prohibés
d'aller chez des amis milliardaires et
d'aller dans un endroit trou trop chic
comme les saint jean cap ferrat
oui oui complètement mais en fait valéry
giscard d'estaing ne voulait pas changer
alors ses habitudes avant ils partaient
en vacances avec toute sa famille un peu
partout il partait en italie dans le sud
de la france et donc pour son premier
arrêté
il voulait continuer à se montrer
justement les vacances c'est le moment
où je retrouve ma famille et donc ils
allaient chez des amis avec tous ses
enfants fin et c'était la tactique de
valéry giscard d'estaing qui conduisait
lui-même sa voiture qu'on dirait montait
les champs-elysées à pied est pas
complètement d'ailleurs pour ce premier
départ en vacances
anémone et les enfants étaient partis
avant lui et lui a fait la route seul au
volant de sa voiture il s'était arrêté
dans une prison je le raconte à nouvion
parce qu'il y avait eu il y avait eu des
mutineries à l'époque où il avait serré
la main de gens qui n'avaient pas encore
été condamné c'est ce qui l'a dit lui
même parce que j'avais choc évidemment
son électorat de droite conservateur on
ne serre pas la main d'un prisonnier
si il est encore innocent voilà une
première étape des vacances c'est ça
donc déjà donc c'est s'il y avait un
vrai changement et deuxième étape donc
des vacances chez des amis à saint jean
cap ferrat où il se montre au début
alors il est très discret d'ailleurs les
journalistes veulent un peu des photos
et tout et après ils se montrent ils
montrent tout même on peut diriger
contrôler tout ça alors il ya chez
giscard d'estaing il ya brégançon il va
y aller il va y aller évidemment
anémone var des chorégraphes on nous
l'avait dit les meubles provençaux un
peu ce qui reste aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
oui oui le style a pas vraiment là
vraiment gêné il a une fin il faut quand
même un petit un gros changement il
instant une plage privée y avait pas de
plage privée à brégançon c'est quand
même extraordinaire non non c'était
alors il y avait une sorte de petite
plage mais elle était à juste à côté
d'un camping bref c'était pas très
agréable qu'il y avait des courants qui
ramenait des des eaux des déchets sur la
plage il fallait nettoyer tous les jours
et valéry giscard d'estaing adorait
nager donc il fallait vraiment un
endroit pour nager comme il n'y avait
pas piscine à l'époque et est donc il
l'a fait construire une sorte de deux
plages mais en béton vous savez un peu
comme un embarcadère mais par contre il
y avait 175 marche pour descendre à la
plage donc le fils de valéry giscard
d'estaing louis giscard d'estaing me
racontait que quand on oubliait son tube
de crème solaire
c'était un peu embêtant parce qu'il
fallait remonter les 175 marc j ai dit
une anecdote très amusante que vous
racontez c'est que le président giscard
d'estaing beaucoup le tennis partout il
va y aide un court de tennis sauf abri
dans son élan il allait chez le voisin
oui ils sont
vitesse chez le voisin au début il était
gagée bienvenue mais après il faisait un
peu trop souvent
oui le voisin qui avait qui étaient
propriétaires du château de brégançon
avec beaucoup beaucoup de terrain aussi
beaucoup d'hectares dont qu'ils avaient
vu un court de tennis et donc vont
beaucoup plus luxueuses résidences non
complètement et puis finalement il était
au départ ils étaient ravis d'avoir le
président vous imaginez alors souvent le
président menée avec son propre prof de
sport donc mais il les invitait de temps
en temps à jouer un peu avec lui il le
laisse à gagner parce qu'il ne
supportait pas trop de perdre et puis un
jour je crois que c'était pour le
week-end du 15 août
il a appelé en disant j'arrive j'arrive
ce week-end pour pour ma partie de
tennis ils ont dit à maintenant mais
nous on n'est pas là on est chez des
amis devant casutt vous ne pouvez pas
venir le lundi
mais comment vous pouvez me refuser ça
je suis le président de la république il
ne comprenait pas lui ve pour lui tout
où tous les alentours tout le voisinage
était à lui
oui en tout cas ils pouvaient s'y
introduire voilà sans que ça gêne
surtout c'est ça gêne il ya évidemment
une partie des vacances devait giscard
d'estaing sur lequel on sait moins de
choses mais à l'époque ils sont cachés
pas tellement c'est qu'il aimait la
chasse est il allé chercher partout où
ils le pouvaient et la terre entière aux
frais des territoires de chasse assez
extraordinaire à l'époque on va le voir
en roumanie par exemple mais là c'est
l'hiver l'été il était très souvent en
afrique on se savait n'en a pas d'image
voilà c'est ça on le savait si on
regarde les journaux télévisés de
l'époque la leur souvent parce que
valéry giscard d'estaing profitait d'un
voyage officiel en afrique mi-juillet
continuer sur une une semaine de safari
et donc les jt de l'époque parlait de le
président valéry giscard d'estaing et en
étant naf pays pour une semaine de
chasse mais on s'était s'était pas sûr
s'il y avait quand même quelque chose de
mystérieux parce que je pense que là on
le voit il chasse du gros gibier des
desserts d'aider les chevreuils mais
mais mais là bas il chassait vraiment dû
je pense les big five
voila voila c'est comme c'est comme les
chasses de juan carlos en espagne ne
sais pas si ça aurait été aujourd'hui ce
serait très mal vu à l'époque je pense
pas que ça aurait yaris 3 mois que
j'étais adolescent à l'époque le canard
enchaîné
on est régulièrement les chasses de
giscard ce n'était pas très bien vu déjà
non pas l'acte de chasse et mais le fait
de chasser des animaux sauvages des
animaux déjà à l'époque était protégé
alors évidemment il le faisait dans un
cadre il ne faisait pas en cachette un
les présidents des des pays respectifs
le lieu tôt risée mais un peu comme les
voisins du voyage mais mais mais mais là
ce qui est sûr par contre c'est que
personne ne savait vraiment où ils
étaient et personne ne pouvait le
contacter il ouellet pendant cette
semaine en afrique autant quand il était
à brégançon où ailleurs en france
il gardait quand même un contact avec
l'elysée là il n'avait aucun contact
avec l'elysée il fallait vraiment qui
est une énorme catastrophe pour
quinconces pour que son aide de camp qui
était à 20 km dans un petit village
vienne vienne le chercher autrement il
ne voulait c'était vraiment une semaine
particulière ou où ce n'était pas le
grand luxe lui qui était habitué au
château justement où il vivait vraiment
de où il dormait sur rien du tout une
ayasse ou quelque chose comme savent où
ils se douchent est très peu est
vraiment mais par contre c'était sa
passion il se lever très tôt il chassait
l'élan de derby et l'élan de derby c'est
une sorte de d'antilopes immense avec
une grotte d'aider des grosses cornes
très très dur très très difficile a
chassé visiblement et donc son rêve
c'était de tuer un élan de derby alors
il faut dire que valéry giscard
d'estaing avait lui-même son château il
en est même deux à l'époque ça faisait
beaucoup d'ailleurs jacques chirac
s'achètera un château avant d'être
premier ministre et pompidou lui en fera
le reproche d'ailleurs il
il avait dit quand on quand on veut
faire de la politique on n'achète pas un
chaplin dans la baignoire de la voir
depuis dans la famille depuis plusieurs
générations dans lequel il n'ira jamais
en vacances par milan après une fois
président jacques chirac ligne à gmail a
aussi aussi bien jusqu'à ce que chirac
avait un château on n'en fait pas des
tonnes sur 7 sur cette affaire ça choque
et moi que ça ne choquerait aujourd'hui
on n'imagine pas un de nos présidents de
la république découvrir qu'il a à
château aujourd'hui ce serait très mal
vu non en plus là c'était c'était un
château de allant lui il avait un
château de famille à shannon à lui était
maire de chamalières et à chanonat et
puis à hotton c'est là où ils allaient
passer des vacances donc c'est près de
tours au top
c'était un château de famille mais
d'anne aymone giscard d'estaing fun et
oui en effet perdre personne n'en
parlait d'ailleurs ce n'était pas
vraiment médiatisée il ya le mariage
d'une de ses filles qui avait été
médiatisée là bas mais mais personne
n'entrait un peu comme dans la boisserie
finalement personne n'entrait dans ce
château n'y avait pas les journalistes à
ce moment là et personne où il ne
faisait l'histoire là dessus c'était des
vacances relativement simple à hotton il
chassait ch
et puis anémone jardiner ils se
baignaient il avait une piscine
contrairement à brégançon et un vol de
tennis voilà c'était plus sympathique à
brégançon d'ailleurs c'est finalement
valéry giscard d'estaing allait à
brégançon parce que c'était l'héritage
de de gaulle de pompidou mais ils
passaient grand maximum quinze jours
après il passait surtout ses vacances à
hotton sachant qu'à l'époque les
vacances étaient encore assez longue
à c alors on a bien compris que dès
l'instant où françois mitterrand arrive
au pouvoir
tout ce qu'on vient de voir ses l'ancien
régime donc il faut se distinguer donc
françois mitterrand n'ira jamais ou
quasiment jamais résume en reléguant son
c'est considéré comme les ors de la
république
il n'ira pas là mais ce non plus et lui
ça y va alors lui qui avait passé toute
c était jusque-là hossegor dans les
landes s'est acheté une maison à lecce
et tout à coup la che va devenir la
résidence officielle du président de la
république
on le voit là avec son petit-fils et il
va y habitait alors les membres du
gouvernement ses amis mais aussi très
vite les chefs d'état l'atce va devenir
véritablement va faire partie du paysage
républicain français pendant les
quatorze années que françois mitterrand
va pas c'est l'elysée on fait une pause
et on s'intéresse aux vacances de
mitterrand
[Musique]
l'elysée à la plage c'est le titre du
livre de pierrick j'ai nous en sommes à
françois mitterrand alors à quoi
ressemblaient les vacances de françois
mitterrand avait oublié aujourd'hui
justement alors mitterrand n'allait pas
à brégançon mais il a fait de sa
bergerie à latché une sorte de brégançon
bis si je puis dire parce que c'est
devenu alors que c'était une résidence
privée
c'est devenu une sorte de résidence
public il accueillait tout le monde des
chefs d'état et des étrangers des
ministres des journalistes des artistes
qu'il s'entourait beaucoup d'artistes
donc c'est devenu vraiment un lieu
familier pour les français cette
bergerie tout bon là on la voyait dans
les médias chaque été mais aussi les
interviews qu'il donne est il ya eu la
fameux le fameux scandale de la grue de
l'atce quand la première année la grue
de la télévision française d'un papa
veut pas parvenu à être installés et
qu'on n'a pas eu les images de
l'interview il y a eu quelques
allocutions de de mitterrand à la che
c'est devenu c'est alors qu'au départ
c'était une bergerie qui ressemblait pas
à grand chose
il l'a beaucoup rénové il a acheté
beaucoup de terrain à ce que son rêve
c'était d'avoir beaucoup des trains
grands propriétaires de forêts
finalement ils voulaient de la forêt
autour
et puis il ne faisait pas grand chose il
se prenait beaucoup avec son chien
famille et puis il nourrissait ces deux
ânes si les puits il lisait mitterrand
lisait beaucoup il profitait de l'été
pour lire
donc c'est des vacances au fond neutre
est de gauche ou quoi
oui complètement complètement est alors
c'était surtout on va peut-être
l'aborder des vacances officielles il se
laissait il invite les journalistes à la
che et il se montrait avec ses deux fils
avec danielle mitterrand fin mais c'est
qu'il y avait à côté d'autres vacances
les vacances cacher les vacances
secrètes et les vacances à gordes les
vacances à gordes c'est les vacances
avec la famille cachée en c'est donc
avec anne pingeot et mazarine et
finalement donc en fait comme comme
pompidou valéry giscard d'estaing avant
lui
au début de ses vacances mitterrand
invitait les journalistes à le prendre
en photo à la che puis une fois que les
journalistes étaient partis il était
tranquille et donc là il allait à gordes
dans le lubéron retrouver
anne et mazarine pingeot garde qui est
la moins touristique qu'aujourd'hui on
l'aurait vu beaucoup moins touristique
d'ailleurs où c'est lui mitterrand
arrivé à s'y promener avec une paire de
lunettes de soleil et un chapeau
on savait à peu près qu'il était on se
demandait à l'époque qui était la petite
fille qui était toujours avec lui mais
personne ne se posait vraiment de
questions mais c'est vrai que à gordes
il avait finalement une toute petite
maison à vraiment je crois qu'il y avait
deux chambres s'étaient vraiment une
petite maison juste pour eux c'était
vraiment cette bulle familiale e3 et
aucun aucun garde du corps aucun
conseiller n'avait le droit d'entrer
dans cette maison c'était vraiment les
gardes du corps il était logé à l'hôtel
quelques kilomètres plus loin il
personne personne ne voyait cette wilaya
vais vraiment ce côté d'ailleurs vous
savez mitterrand tous les week-ends il
allait aussi à souzy la briche et à
souzy la briche y laisser leur résidence
officielle celle-là c'était une
résidence officielle qu'il est le seul
président élu seul président à l'avoir
utilisé parce que après nicolas sarkozy
a récupéré la lanterne à versailles
on va voir la donne et il a donné sourit
la briche à françois fillon qui
finalement ne donnait françois fillon
faut comprendre que c'était la résidence
officielle du premier ministre
la lente elle enterre verra sa valeur et
et comme mieux le président de la
république sarkozy l'a pris en
dédommagement il a laissé au premier
ministre de sa décision
voilà qui est et qui était le lieu
vraiment de lui un des lieux importants
dans l'histoire
mitterrand un jour il y passait tous
leurs week end il y mène est presque une
vie normale si je puis dire il y avait
quelques amis qui les a mis au courant
il venait un gardien qui qui se
taisaient quelques domestique mais c'est
tout donc c'était vraiment c'est
vraiment deux lieux importants de
l'histoire d'amour
anne françois mitterrand ses gardes et
souzy la briche
alors arrive jacques chirac jacques
chirac eux revient à brégançon et il
veut faire peuple
ça c'est le premier était plein chirac
donc il ya cette fameuse photo où on le
voit à brégançon en caleçon avec des
chaussettes et des chaussures de ville
moi je donne la seule explication je me
dis il l'a fait exprès il veut montrer à
france aux français qu'il est comme eux
oui c'est un peu ça et puis jacques
chirac il a toujours été un peu
maladroit la dodo il y avait vous
souvenez après ce avant ce concert de
madonna qu'il y avait eu au parc de sauf
eux
il s'était fait prendre en photo avec un
casque de walkman et un sweat à capuche
donc il ya toujours ces fers jeunes pour
faire jeune et là c'est un peu c'est un
peu dans le même esprit finalement pas
vraiment vous voyez c'est vraiment de
mauvais goût les chaussettes avec les
chaussures mais mais oui je pense qu'il
voulait être un français parce que
normal en vacances je suis pas sûr que
les français à l'époque s'habiller comme
ça pour partir en vacances mais il ya un
côté anti mitterrand là on le voit bien
que le veut le premier oui incomplet si
mitterrand il revient oublie d'ailleurs
il y en a des dents sophie ciel il
revient dans sa maison à lui il fait pop
complètement il a passé son premier
était à brégançon et son dernier été de
président à brégançon il a vraiment fait
une boucle comme ça voilà que brégançon
que bernadette chirac varrault décoré
comme elle a redécoré tous les palais de
la reine anne d'auray la fréquenter y
compris la lanterne quand il était
premier ministre
mais évidemment ça se fume partie des
vacances de jacques chirac qui lui adore
aller à l'étranger puis les et il va y
avoir le fameux scandale quand on va
découvrir que à l'étranger parfois il
lui arrive d'aller au royal palm à l'île
maurice qui est un palace hors de prix
et là on va commencer à lui demander des
comptes
avec chirac parce que alors jacques
chirac adore le soleil sa passion c'est
juste bronzer seins il passe sa journée
à la plage pendant pendant ses vacances
et donc il a ses habitudes royal palm
qui est un palace de l'île maurice ou ou
sont passé à peu près toutes les
célébrités de catherine deneuve être
toutes les têtes couronnées voilà et
mais c'est des vacances finalement
personne n'a mis vraiment le nez dans
ses vacances et et en 2000 paris-match
décide de
av deux mois avant les vacances d'été de
faire deux reportages différents 1 sur
les vacances de lionel jospin à l'île de
ré et un premier ministre premier
ministre voilà et un de jacques chirac à
l'île maurice et là on va découvrir
vraiment des vacances de milliardaires
avec u2 suite différentes une pour
bernadette chirac l'une pour jacques
chirac
une pour claude chirac et puis il ya
aussi tous tous les conseillers qui
suivent enfin le l'aide de camp voilà et
donc des vacances hors de prix
finalement avec vraiment d'aider d'une
chambre luxueuse et et jacques chirac ne
va pas être content il va vraiment en
vouloir à paris match à ce moment là
alors que il a ses habitudes il donne
souvent des entretiens vais y accordent
souvent des entretiens paris match et et
là il va pas être content parce qu'il
aura pas maîtrisé finalement cette
communication présidentielle alors que
jusqu'à maintenant finalement les
vacances c'était un moment aussi où il
arrivait à renvoyer l'image qu'il
voulait par exemple il s'est montré avec
son petit-fils martin chirac
justement on va le voir parce que il a
médiatisé ses vacances alors pas au
royal palm est la réunion est la réunion
on veut avoir des idées image et à
l'époque que paris match et ai montré
alors avec le petit fils et on le voit
on voit bien qu'ils aiment ceux des
grands resorts comme ça très cher c'est
ça n'est pas gênant il ne choque
personne
l époque le royal palm c'est parce qu'il
est mis en compétition avec avec lionel
jospin qui lui avait à l'île de ré uk et
qu'on voit on se dit sur le plan
électoral évidemment ses meilleurs des
leaders et vous avez raison il n'a pas
apprécié parce que c'est pas lui qui
avait décidé qu'on fasse ce reportage
mais met en effet ça ça ça choque pas
encore comme comme ça choquerait
aujourd'hui vous imaginez aujourd'hui ça
serait vraiment je ne sais pas ce que
fera le président mais ça ne s'est pas
encore oui ça ça dérange personne
oui à la réunion c'était cet été des
cerises séchées et surtout ce n'est pas
repris par par l'opposition personne non
un argument absolument pas de même c'est
un président qui aime disparaître et là
où on va en avoir la preuve c'est le
fameux été 2003 l'été de là canicule ou
tout à coup donc on s'aperçoit qu'il
fait très chaud et qu'il ya un certain
nombre de seniors qui
qui quitterait pas sa force de subir
cette chaleur qui était quand même
terriblement accablante
on arrive on parvient tout juste à voir
le mais le pré le ministre de la santé
jean françois mattei qui en plus est
interviewé en chemisette
il est en vacances et ce qui fait
très mauvais effet et suta coup les
français réalisent que pendant les
vacances
leurs ministres leur président sont en
vacances ce qui compte vraiment complète
sauf que là ce moment là on est plus et
plus le septennat c'est déjà le cas qena
est le quinquennat tout à coup on se dit
bah non c'est trop court ils peuvent
plus avoir de vacances parce que au
moment de la canicule jacques chirac va
réapparaître très longtemps après après
le scandale au fond ah oui complètement
il disparaît complètement alors il donc
il est dans un petit village au canada
sans grand intérêt ou bernadette chirac
passe son temps à faire du shopping est
allé chez le coiffeur donc il ya
vraiment rien à faire dans ce village et
me donc au début ces vacances sont un
peu médiatisé il ya quelques
journalistes et tout d'un coup il
disparaît mais vraiment il disparaît
même certains viennent à se demander
s'il est encore dans ce village canadien
ou ici les palais aux etats unis se
faire une petite opération de chirurgie
esthétique ou s'il a pas retrouvé une de
ces îles paradisiaques lé dans
lesquelles ils aiment aller et aucun mot
donc de jacques chirac sur la canicule
il réagira au conseil des ministres de
rentrée dans la cour de l'elysée mais
mais ça sera déjà passé à ce moment là
on comptait déjà des morts et finalement
on lui a reproché complètement à lyon
n'a presque plus reprocher amah téhoua
raffarin avait misé de l'époque que oui
à jean pierre raffarin premier ni c'est
l'époque où k jacques chirac et la place
qu aussi à l'époque on était encore dans
au fond dans l'idée que le général de
gaulle se faisait du de de la vème
république à savoir il ya un
gouvernement qui gouverne depuis ya un
président qui préside
il a de la distance alors là jacques
chirac il avait montré qu'il avait
vraiment beaucoup de distance distance
complètement d mettra à l'essai ont fait
et comme nous gazer avec le pagne a
vraiment une rupture je pense pas le
passage du septennat au quinquennat et
les français là se disent maintenant le
président n'a que 5 ans vont mettre en
oeuvre son projet comme on dit cinq ans
parce que il n'est pas réélu en plus un
depuis le passage au quinquennat les
prisons ne sont pas réélus et bien donc
il a plus le temps de se reposer il a
plus le temps de souffler vous imaginez
mitterrand 14 ans pouvoir deux
septennats
on se disait il doit justement prendre
le temps de prendre du repos pour pour
prendre du recul sur sa politique
maintenant dire un président en a pas
de prendre des vacances il est président
à plein temps pendant cinq ans mais
parce qu'il est président et premier
ministre voilà aussi est au sifflet
évidemment alors c'est nicolas sarkozy
au fond qu'il à découvrir que le seuil
de tolérance des français et des médias
ont complètement changé
et évidemment son premier été il fait de
l'anti chirac
on l'a bien compris le premier était ça
consiste toujours à faire le contraire
du précédent et donc il ya eu tellement
d'histoire d'argent avec jacques chirac
qui on reproche d'avoir un peu trop
profité des subsides de la république
nicolas sarkozy il décide de faire l'
inverse
creel son première était il va chez des
amis milliardaires aux états unis il y
là ça coûte rien aux français ils vont
rien dire
patatras c'est le scandale c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est le l'été le
plus rocambolesque qui soit dans ce
livre justement il se passe tellement de
choses dans cet été ils décident pour
faire plaisir à son épouse cécilia
sarkozy
il ne voulait plus d'eux ils
s'entendaient plus d'ailleurs ils
divorceront deux mois après cet été
c'est un peu finalement
l'été de la dernière chance d'ailleurs
ils essaient de de retrouver cécilia et
donc elle veut absolument aller
retrouver des amis milliardaires à ows
bureaux aux états unis au bord d'un lac
américain fin
là encore il ya via par un grand grand
intérêt à voir le bourreau on comprend
pas c'est pas finalement comme chirac
qui va à l'île maurice on comprend
finalement y est c'est paradisiaque
goldboro c'est loin d'être paradisiaque
est d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy va
beaucoup s'ennuyer pendant cet été là
parce que à part faire un peu de canoë
kayak et faire du footing il ne fait
rien c'est le fameux été on le voit
faire du footing avec un t-shirt new
york police department complète qui lui
sera beaucoup reproché aussi
complètement il passe les trois premiers
jours donc à faire du footing
photographier là il ya les journalistes
et journaliste américain les
journalistes françaises il se laisse en
en photo et puis au bout de trois jours
il fait une conférence de presse dans un
parc et il dit voilà maintenant vous
pouvez rentrer chez vous je ne vous
donnerai plus rien plus d'image il avait
décidé que c'était fini maintenant ses
vacances de nay privé chien est alors
les journalistes français ont plutôt
accepter un cette recommandation
présidentielle
mais les journalistes américains ne
s'est pas du tout dans leur culture
un président ne désire pas quand il se
fait photographier quand il ne se fait
pas photographe et donc le lendemain
enfin deux photographes américains se
sont mis sur un kayak et ils ont
commencé à photographier nicolas sarkozy
qui faisait du kayak avec eux ses amis
avec cécilia sarkozy et avec rachida
dati garde des sceaux à l'époque
personne ne savait qu'elle était avec
les sarkozy à voile bourreau est donc là
nicolas sarkozy a pété les plombs
on peut le dire il a pété les plombs
parce qu'il est même monté sur le bateau
ouvre des deux photographes
il leur a pris à pellicule il était prêt
à jeter à l'eau il paraît que cécilia
sarkozy la retenue et les américains
n'aiment pas du tout sauf voilà et ça
aurait pu faire un vrai scandale
diplomatique finalement que le président
français réagissent comme ça donc
premier couac de ses vacances
deuxième couac de ses vacances il a dû
faire un aller-retour pour les obsèques
du carnet d cardinal lustiger à paris
vous imaginez en avion du glam
voilà mais en une journée et demie il a
fait un aller-retour pour des obsèques à
notre dame
donc là aussi ça passait pas trop et
puis troisième couac
il sait si la sarkozie avait été invité
par madame bouche à un barbecue familial
chez les bush avec bush père et bush
fils qui était alors président des états
unis et à la dernière minute cécilia
sarkozy n'est pas venu
nicolas sarkozy est allé tout seul et
l'excusent c'était que cécilia sarkozy
avait une angine blanche
mais ce qui est bizarre c'est qu'au même
moment elle était photographiée en train
de lézarder sur la plage à voile boro
visiblement n'était pas très malade et
donc là aussi ça aurait pu on a évité le
scandale diplomatique parce que pour que
la première dame s'absente du barbecue
de de l'invitation que lui avait fait la
first lady
ça aurait pu faire un scandale
médiatique donc j'imagine et il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de quark dans cet été
et ça a été vraiment il ya eu un
tournant cet été à goldboro après cela
nicolas sarkozy choisira des vacances
avec sa seconde épouse carla bruni
sarkozy au cap dans la résidence
des bruni et des vacances plutôt serial
finalement familiale complètement avec
toute la famille bruni et on voit bien
que c'est à partir de ce moment là qu'il
ya un certain nombre d'interdictions
on se dit
un va pas on va plus chez les
milliardaires on va plus à l'étranger
que les transitions et alors on peut
encore prendre des vacances cette époque
là ça va être interdite après avec
françois hollande on va le voir mais à
l'époque il prend il continue quand même
de prendre des vacances mais chez dans
la villa dans la maison du cap de
la famille bruni il va commencer à faire
venir des chefs d'état il montre qu'il
travaille quand même complètement il
fait venir un peu comme mitterrand à la
che il il faut cette résidence des bruni
très très belle un beaucoup plus belle
que brégançon que le fort de brégançon
fin va devenir une sorte de deux lieux
où il reçoit aussi bien des ministres
que des chefs d'état en même temps que
souvent les amis artistes de de carla de
carla bruni justement il y aura
justement un dîner entre gens là avec
jean louis borloo
leonardo dicaprio et le mannequin naomi
campbell est pareil que jean-louis
borloo ne savait pas trop où ce maître
et est donc nicolas sarkozy y va quand
même être un président au travail en
vacances d'ailleurs il organisera comme
le cap et la maison du cap
est juste à côté du fort de brégançon
il organisera à un petit sommet
économique de rentrer avec ses ministres
à brégançon pendant ses vacances il ira
plus d'une fois à l'étranger aussi en
déplacement pendant ses vacances
donc finalement le président en vacances
commencent à être un président au
travail au bord de la mer en qu'elle
annoncerait change encore plus avec
françois hollande qui décide de faire de
l'anti sarkozy le premier était de son
mandat donc qui décide d'aller à
brégançon surtout pas dans sa maison à
mougins
parce que nous vient c'est un endroit
assez chic de la côte d'azur il y a une
très jolie maison mais je dis c'est pas
le moment de montrer ma maison à mougins
on va l'avoir d'ailleurs et donc on va à
brégançon et on y va en train sauf que
et le scandale parce que on accuse
valérie trierweiler d'avoir acheté des
coussins hors de prix pour brégançon ce
qui est à mourir de rire quand on sait
les sommes qui ont été jusque là
consacré par les précédentes épouses des
présidents à la redécoration de
brégançon voilà là on reproche rien
c'est à dire 12 coussin oui 12
1 avec un peu d'une marque barcelonaise
un petit peu cher mais vraiment c'est
pas grand-chose série mais qu'une voilà
l affaire est révélée quelques jours
avant le départ en vacances et c'est
vrai que ça fait scandale
et l'argument est repris à l'époque par
l'opposition par la droite qui pointe du
doigt ce président qui se veut normal et
qui est finalement redécore brégançon
donc on part quand même la sphère des
coussins de blagues droite comparé en
quelque sorte la sphère des coussins
brégançon au fouquet's de sarkozy vous
savez que nicolas sarkozy est allé au
fouquet's le soir de son élection
donc finalement les vacances de françois
hollande de ce président qui se veut
normal qui va aller à brégançon en train
avec valérie trierweiler très mal à
l'aise derrière qui n'aime pas du tout
cette mise en scène françois hollande
qui juste avant de prendre le train me
sera vu à la fnac en train d'acheter des
dvd des livres d'amazon dans norma là
comme un président normal
il voulait jouer un peu a largué la
merkel qui engueule a.merkel tous les
ans elle descend dans le même hôtel
elle fait la même randonnée elle a
habillé avec la même chemise à carreaux
on voit tous les ans il ya la même photo
d'angela merkel qui fait de la randonnée
la montagne elle qui est la chancelière
normal mais c'est beaucoup plus simple
pour angela merkel dette une chancelière
normal que françois hollande un
président normal en vacances alors lui
il valait beaucoup à la lanterne donc
qui est ce fameux pavillon dans le
château de versailles qu'on va voir en
photo que donc nicolas sarkozy l'adorait
il avait donc ravi au premier ministre
françois fillon
et c'est à la lanterne donc et qui est
ici qui va passer lens est normalement
une résidence plutôt de week end à
montpellier ça c'est l'était également
et puis il va disparaître plusieurs fois
françois hollande qui lui est obligé de
travailler a réduit ses vacances à
portion congrue il ya pratiquement plus
de vacances mais il dit qu'il arrive à
disparaître notamment une fois que
révéler sa
sa liaison avec julie gayet il va
réussir à disparaître on imagine qu'il
est avec julie gayet mais au fond on
n'en sait rien et puis arrive mais
emmanuel macron et là le premier était
c'est capital là aussi alors qu'est ce
qu'ils décident de faire emmanuel macron
pour son premier était alors emmanuel
macron pour son première était il
voulait aller à brégançon fin mai
françois hollande qui avait ouvert
brégançon au public après son premier
arrêté désastre à brégançon y avait des
dix jeunes me remettrai plus jamais les
pieds je vais l'ouvrir au public et
françois hollande avait renouvelé
l'ouverture publique de brégançon pour
un été supplémentaires on a d'ailleurs
vu qu'il avait voulu faire un
pied-de-nez à emmanuel macron avec pour
le priver de vagues voilà donc emma
daumas qu'on ne pouvait pas aller à
briançon
donc il est allé chez un ami préfet
voilà à marseille et
et donc c'est des vacances au début
d'ailleurs qu'on voulait garder plutôt
discrète parce que une semaine voilà que
mène oui oui c'était assez court
et puis on voulait au début garder et du
décès vacances plutôt discrète mais
maintenant il ya les réseaux sociaux et
donc qui venait d'arriver à marseille il
y avait déjà eu une photo de lui ces
jeunes vont ils avaient fini par les
mettre en scène
parce qu'il est allé se faire
photographier avec les joueurs de
l'olympique de marseille avec emmanuel
macron et là il a il a bien il a réalisé
que il ya on prend plus de vacances en
fait on n'arrête pas de travailler
d'ailleurs tout le monde va le plaisanté
sur le fait que sur son jet ski à
brégançon en fait il a un téléphone et
règle les problèmes du monde
on va montrer qu'on va pas chez les
riches qu'on va pas à l'étranger
on travaille et tout ça est très bien
intégré mais quand même
à brégançon il va faire construire la
piscine que tous ses prédécesseurs
avaient rêvé et sans jamais pouvoir le
faire parce que c'est un site classé et
lui il a la bonne idée
c'est surtout que ça s'est beaucoup
développé deux pays il ya la piscine
hors sol voilà donc on n'abîme pas le
bâtiment ont fait une piscine hors sol
est là aussi ce qu'amd a évidemment
scandale alors que ce projet de piscine
date d'il ya très longtemps en rêvant
sont claude pompidou ou les faire une
piscine à brégançon
carla bruni avait dit que si son mari
était réélu elle ferait une piscine à
brégançon alors qu'ils allaient un
week-end par an et alors là emmanuel
macron qui lui réinvesti vraiment
vraiment il y va vraiment je sais le
sait le premier président qui va autant
faim il décide de faire cette piscine or
ce qui coûte finalement moins cher que
de déployer toute la sécurité quand le
président de va se baigner dans la mer
williams r épublique devoir faire
attention mais mais mais ça va faire
scandale d'ailleurs françois hollande
l'avait en quelque sorte un peu prévenu
en dix ans les français veulent que leur
président aille à brégançon
mais ils ne veulent pas qu'ils dépensent
1 sous 1 euro pour brégançon fois pour
mettre un peu plus de confort à
brégançon
emmanuel macron acheter un peu d'huile
sur le feu parce que ce premier était
justement il y aura eu le scandale de la
piscine lors d'un de ces bains de foule
devant devant vraiment sauf une dame va
lui parler de sa piscine et dire à moi
je préfère me baigner dans la mer et
donc ça ça faisait ça faisait un peu
mauvais genre parce qu'après le tout le
scandale qu'il y avait eu après c'est un
scandale qui un peu comme les coussins
de brégançon s'est très vite redescendu
quand même si oui mais sa mls mais mais
ça laisse quand même clé ça montre aussi
que je parle de tolérance mais on
pourrait presque parler de puritanisme
on est devenus très puritain par rapport
à aux vacances de dos président non
seulement ils n'ont plus droit aux
vacances mais ils ont plus le droit de
sourire ils ont plus le droit d'être
heureux ils ont bu le droit c'est très
mal vu
et notre président normalement il doit
travailler tout le temps il doit porter
un masque grave parce que les événements
quels qu'ils soient sont graves et
complètement et quand emmanuel macron se
montre sur son jet ski parce que ça
c'est son s'est pas vu assez mal vu on
commence à dire que le jet ski c'est
vraiment pas une passion et écologique
il ya toujours quelque chose le
président en vacances doit maintenant
est un président qui reste en costume
comme la avec avec angela merkel et
finalement le président en vacances
maintenant c'est un président il change
de décor il passe de l'elysée à
brégançon
il est en quelque sorte en télétravail à
brégançon merci pierre et que j'ai
d'avoir été mon avis si si je renvoie
votre livre d'élise est à la plage dans
l'intimité de nos présidents en vacances
ça l'air de rien mais en fait c'est une
véritable étude de
de la france des français de leur
président de la république ces rapports
ont énormément changé c'est paru aux
éditions du rocher merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]